[Music]
what is
long-termism and why did you write this
book
well long-termism is about three things
it's about taking seriously the sheer
scale of the future that might be ahead
of us and just how high the stakes are
in anything that could shape that future
it's then about
trying to assess what the events that
might occur in our lifetimes that really
would have impact not just for the
present generation but they could
potentially shape the entire course of
humanity's future
and then third to then to figure out
like okay how do we
ensure that we can take actions to put
humanity onto the right path and i think
you'd exactly like to talk about
personal long-termism and the analogy
there because
in the book in what we are the future i
talk about
the analogy between
the pleasant world and humanity and an
implodent teenager like a reckless
teenager aware there are things you know
what really high stakes decisions that a
teenager makes it's like not what you do
at a weekend instead it's the sort of
it's the decisions that would impact the
entire course of your life
so in the book i'd you know tell a story
where i was quite a reckless teenager i
nearly killed myself climbing up a
building that was one of the biggest
decisions
dumbest decisions like i ever made
because if i had died then
it would have been
60 70 years of life that i would have
lost
in the same way if humanity dies now you
know if we cause although an extinction
or the end of the uncoverable end of
civilization such as by a worst case
pandemic
then we're losing
well not just 70 years of life it's
thousands millions even billions of
years of future civilization
and so similarly if
you know
i made decisions as a teenager that
affected the kind of whole course of my
life like whether to become a poet or a
philosopher or something you know it
could have become a doctor and similarly
i think in the coming essentially in our
lifetime
humanity potentially makes decisions
about you know how is future society
structured what the values we live by
is society
a liberal democracy around the world or
you know is it a totalitarian state
and
how do we handle technologies like ai
that i think could impact the very very
long run so i want to read just a
paragraph that you sent me
which
i found thought provoking because it's a
framing that i had not heard before
and
here it goes
imagine the entire human story from the
first homo sapiens of east africa to our
eventual end
represented as a single life where in
that life do we stand we can't know for
sure but suppose humanity lasted only a
tenth as long as the typical mammalian
species even then more than 99 percent
of this life would lie ahead on the
scale of a typical life humanity today
would just be six months old
but we might well survive even longer
for hundreds of millions of years until
the earth is no longer habitable or far
beyond in that case humanity is
experiencing its first blinking moments
out of the womb
and
i appreciated this framing
because
my feeling at least with my audience of
listeners
is that there's a small percentage who
are rushing headlong into battle with
some vision of long-termism and feel
committed
to fighting the good fight
and a non-trivial percentage
have decided it's too late
right they've decided that
the the end is nigh
we are
the frog
in the water slowly heating that will be
boiling before we know it and
i find this at least
whether we put aside for the second how
people might
find fault with it or pick at it a
useful counter frame right just to even
sit with
for
a few minutes
why do you think it's important to at
least consider
that something like this is
plausible maybe it's not 90 percent
likely but let's just say it's even
10 20 likely
well it's so important just because
future generations matter future people
matter
and whatever you value
whether that's you know well-being or
happiness or maybe it's accomplishment
maybe it's great works of art maybe it's
scientific discovery
almost all of whatever you value would
be in the future rather than now
because the future just could be vast
indeed where
you know again if you look at like what
was what has been accomplished
since the dawn of humanity well dawn of
humanity was the end a thousand years
ago
agriculture was 12 000 years ago
industrial evolution was 250 years ago
and yet
even on the scale of a typical mammal
species we have 700 000 years to go
now we're not typical mammal species we
could last only a few centuries we could
last 10 years if we really do ourselves
in
in the short term but we could last much
longer
and that just means that
all of what we might achieve
all of the good things that humanity
could produce
they're basically in the future and
that's really worth thinking about
taking seriously and trying to protect
and promote
you